not yet
just like to open the meeting today and
welcome everyone here I don't think
there's any apologies
um welcome David on the screen is he
he's not not connected so he'll he'll
come in when he comes in
um we have quite a full agenda quite a
big paper from the property group
Katrina is it
and um
we'll just we'll
get into it
um
I don't think we need to do anything
that's basically
get straight into the first item and
it's the executive summary on the
development contributions issues and
options paper and it's quite a lengthy
bit of paper and um Katrina I would like
to would you like to speak to that yes
sure thank you so I'm Katrina Ellis from
the property group planning consultant
for gordoship Council
um so it is a lengthy paper and I take
it as read so we're happy to take
questions but just to summarize it's
come about on the back of the work of
the proposed District plan and having to
make a decision about whether there'll
be Financial contributions in the
proposed District plan or not and also
we're looking to app Zone certain areas
and as part of that need to kind of have
a bit of a idea about what
infrastructure might need to be upgraded
and how that will be funded in order to
be able to unlock the potential
out of that development
um at Mark's opportunities there so
we've already tabled the issues and
options paper with the district plans
subcommittee but
um I understand it has to come to this
committee to be decided upon if we take
the development if we go away and
develop a development contributions
policy so as per the issues and options
paper
we've landed on developing a development
contributions policy as a preferred
option for ensuring that there is
opportunity to collect money to help
fund infrastructure going forward and
development contributions policies
there's uh a bit less risk with it than
financial contributions because
Financial contributions are on the RMA
and there's RMA reforms at the moment
and they're also a bit more specific
um
so yeah at this stage we're just looking
for approval seeking to see if you're
willing to approve for us to formulate
that policy and at a later date kind of
issues and options and
the dollar cost of contributions and who
may have to pay or come back to council
or committee for consideration of you
know the detail of the policy itself
as uh anyone got questions of Katrina
there's quite I think I've got some but
open up the floor first joke
all right thank you Mr chair
um through you the
developer contributions
um what are we currently using because I
have heard some businesses are talking
about
developer contributions but is it not
currently under a policy or how's it
been working today
um yep so there's a few things there so
in terms of an actual policy there is
currently a development contributions
policy however as limited to Commercial
and Industrial developments with a value
of half a million dollars or above so
the council is collecting development
contributions at the moment but for a
very limited number of developments and
not for residential development at the
moment but the other way councils
funding infrastructure upgrades at the
moment as if somebody wants to do a
resource consent and that requires for
example a road to be upgraded it's on
that one developer to fund and do all
the works and what we've seen is some
consents just haven't eventuated because
Pete that makes it not financially
viable for someone to proceed
mcvale through the chair um just one
question I've got the the thing that
we're doing some Case by case at the
moment so some aren't getting charged as
much as others is that correct so I've
just heard in one or two discussions
that concerns me because I'm just not
sure whether
is a policy at the moment for those
commercial and Industrial developments
and that's got a specific calculation
and formula at the moment which that's
out a dollar value
um so if somebody wants to contest that
I think they can
um but there is a clear formula as to
what that contribution should be
so sorry follow on from it so that we
have discretion as a council for that is
it because I understand there's a couple
of ones we've done that haven't been
done on the same scale and I'm just
wondering why that was or whether it's
with this takes care of it in the future
I'm not sure the answer to that question
no that's okay
thanks
just to comment I think in the past
people have appealed that has appealed
for um Leicester money amount
and um I know of two that's probably
happened and um but what what's actually
happened is inflation's move that the
500 000 level is going to capture a lot
more
from now going forward
Keith apologies for lateness
um the
um is set out in the report a number of
the financial contributions have been
under balance since
2016. but the one that is still there is
the development contribution and the
proceeds that is there
um enables people to object to that and
staff have a delegation to a certain
extent but if it can't be resolved then
it's required to be considered by
Council
um so the the formula that's there sets
out the maximum amount but for the
large-scale developments there's always
a bit of wriggle room in terms of the
amount paid in the in the way that it's
spent
um I guess that it leads on to the
question in terms of um
uh the there is reference in the report
to the development agreement
is that something that the council has
the ability to do now and I've got
another question after
you Mr chair yes that is something the
counts of ability to do however there
might be limited incentive for
developers where if you had a
development contribution policy for
example then you had a development
agreement as an alternative option
people might see it as favorable to get
a developer agreement
um whereas at the moment a developer
agreement
would require firstly the developer to
want to stump up some money and secondly
if they're not covering the full course
counts would still need a way of funding
the rest of the cost to upgrade
infrastructure so there's just a bit of
a gap there at the moment which means
there's been limited Merit in developer
agreements
so what what is set out in the report is
that a policy be considered as part of
the long-term plan and I'm just thinking
from a practical point of view that it's
not really related to the long-term plan
little gritty numbers stuff
um I'm just wondering Jason how do you
see it going forward I was thinking that
it's probably something uh that can be
developed with the policy and Regulatory
committee coming up with the policy and
um then bring back into the long-term
plan process
um through the chair absolutely I would
agree with that
um I think from the conversation already
around the room you can see why there is
a need for the policy because we do have
a fair bit of ad hoc
um sort of development at the moment a
number of ways that you can capture
um
some contribution from developers but
then certainly it highlights the
um I guess
the level of potential unfairness around
that because we're not operating under
consistent policy um but I would
certainly um
see that
putting it through and aligning with the
ltp is common practice and certainly
then you're able to link it to a
proposed program of works that's
scheduled over that 10 to 30 year period
and so it gives you a basis for setting
your policies around the amount of
development that you anticipate and also
the capital Works program that you are
looking to
see it over that time period
thank you for that answer does that mean
they mean that there is an addition
required to the recommendation
on page four
years I think we have to change that
because it's in conjunction with a
long-term plan
um
sorry through you Mr chair the um let
policy legally has to be done in
conjunction with a long-term plan yes
but in the first since sorry
um so my expectation I'm not a member of
the committee so I can't move it
um so my expectation is that the council
commence the development of development
contribution policy through the policy
and Regulatory committee
for later conclusion inclusion as part
of the long-term plan process
would someone like to move that from the
floor
Stuart would you like to visit thank you
councilor good day
Mr secondary
Susan will read it back to us I think
so the second part of the recommendation
is that the council commits the
development of a development development
contribution policy
through policy and Regulatory committee
for later inclusion
of 2024-34 long-term
evidence thanks councilman
stronger
any more discussion
no discussion although or put that
motion that we um
would you like to repeat that Susan
[Laughter]
contribution policy through the policy
of infiltration nothing
for later inclusion is
thank you all those in favor please say
hi
against
I'm scared
yes
if we turn to page 35 and we have the
monthly compliance update for Jeremy
meter Uma for Gore and Matera from Aaron
thanks Aaron thank you Mr chairman um
I'll take this report as Rick
and happy to take any questions
councilor mcphail told you I had a lot
of dumb questions
um
the the report there where the
environment
um we didn't get a discharge concerned
what what happened there well why did
what's the environment Southland doing
they seem to we send tears down there
and then it came back and went back and
they said it was all right is it
yeah so that one is uh I think on the
stormwater discharge paper which is
still to come
it's gonna be done that's right just
remember it for later
no no further questions
um I'll put the report that the report
be received no sorry Neville Council
uh thank you Mr chair I just got one
question about drippity meters and the
terror I've resumed with the upgrades
things have changed here I know it's
going to be pretty hard to treat that
water when it changes so quickly from
the polarity
uh through you Mr chair yes
um those stupidity meters are being
upgraded as part of the upgrade um we're
finding that really good and reliable
throughout all our plants
so that upgrade will be finished in July
as it August
uh through the chair I think it's uh
later in the years probably around
October yeah
no further
comments on the um
with Tara And gorwin
compliance I'll put the report received
someone like to move that
let's do it
and Ben
all those in our favor please say oh
yeah
engaged
it's carried
page
38 is it 39.
the gore Urban water supply the cube is
well consent annual report for 2022 and
and there's a copy of the annual report
for the cold water supply
um
Matt is that you
yeah Aaron sorry
um thank you Mr chair
this is a condition on our watertake
consent for the Cooper's world and
the update the reporter is written and
happy to take any questions
Australia
uh thank you Mr chair a couple questions
here there
um
so you look at report why are we not
using Troopers One and Two Worlds I see
there's no no total volume metrics
um recorded there through you Mr chair
um when we're needing to actually take
water from Wells one and two they're
already dry
um so they're not quite as deep
and seem to mess up the equifer a bit so
yeah
so and we did get close to taking from
the terror didn't we but not quite yeah
uh you so the day we sent out
notification for the jacobstown
um that we're gonna start pumping uh the
heavens opened and
start filling things back up again so
this year we we were quite lucky and
didn't need to
good
no further Joe it was just careful
Australia uh through you Mr chair
um when will the wells
um last claimed
um so the older Wells and Coopers
um they're not boss so the whales
haven't actually been
um
I've never heard of cleaning a well
before but the boars they were
Jacob's town was redeveloped in 2020
and Coopers is um Court yeah so yeah
now any further questions
we move on at the report we received
uh Neville and Joe thank you
all those in favor please say aye
against
carried
thank you
this is the next one
this one
um page 43 the Jacobs Town emergency
water supply take and discharge
permanent conceit for 2022 and 2023
annual report
um
I'll be Aaron again uh thank you again
Mr chair
um this report is again another
condition of having the emergency water
supply take from the mataro river
as you can see in the report there was
no obstruction taken
um so it was a pretty straightforward
Ford report
maybe to take any questions
no questions
I'll put the report be received over for
that thanks
it's a joke
a secondary Council Australia
all those in favor appreciate
all right against
carried
move over to the um three Waters
quarterly levels of service report
um Aaron again
uh thanks again
um so with this report we've actually
made a couple of changes to it it's
um a year-to-date report now
um compared to the full year the Year
previous
that way we can do a bit more
um viewing of how we're through the
trending and it's a lot more time a lot
less time consuming doing it this way
happy to take any questions
no questions
I'll put that
I'll put the report someone right to
move that report be received
let's do it
and be in there thank you
all those in favor please say aye
against
carried
page 48 stormwater discharge consent for
numbers
uh 206 303 and 206 304 and 206 305
compliance sampling
Aaron
uh yeah thank you Mr chair
um as part of our storm water consent
um we're required to take annual
sampling and
on that we were deemed to be
um
non-compliant
and I felt that was quite harsh so I
asked for them to reassess us upon their
reassessment they deemed that they had
been a bit harsh and and awarded us
compliant on that consent
I'm happy to take any questions
that's right since you've already had
that through yeah councilman
um what's the cost to us for that you
know let's say a time and um all that
sort of stuff
um
through you Mr chair um the costing I
haven't looked at
um but it is a requirement for a
stormwater discharge consents that we
undergo this stormwater monitoring
so sorry through the chair so having to
do it twice that or did you start for a
review on that okay thank goodness
councilor Stringer
uh three Mr chair um why are they not
doing human E coli testing that I just
don't know generic I think I could
answer that one but Gary can answer it
um so there's a lot more cost involved
in in doing the the trace analysis
um so for our consent requirements we
have to do E coli and then if we're over
a thousand
result over a thousand then we have to
do an investigation
um in that investigation that we then go
into tracing and to see if it's human or
or not so that's where we
because of the large cost outlay
thanks Aaron
um
Council Australia yeah further so they
um how many times we've been over
previously and would it be worthwhile
instead of going through investigation I
mean doing the human colon test just
doing from the start to save here the
hassle is that our responsibility or is
that environment cell phone
uh through you Mr chair that would be
our responsibility
um and there are times where a trace
sample can't be taken
um and it needs to be the result to get
a decent
um Trace needs to be well over a
thousand so if we said to the lab we
want to do trace on all our samples then
we would be paying for a lot that can't
be traced so
um and we're just taking off that extra
condition that they've put on for doing
the investigations
it was understated comments and I'll
take I record the rain gauge figures for
the year and we had 137 millimeters of
rain in March and prior to that it was
very dry yeah
would someone like to move that any more
questions first of all
um
no just a query then
so you're a bit concerned about the
discharge
for
four three and four Matera and number 10
and Gore perhaps that um
Maybe
if we were enlightened about where those
discharges were it would probably give
us a better idea about whether it's on
land base or you know straight out of
the
pump stations and whatever it might be
so if I give the Council of a better
idea about where it's where about it is
through you Mr chair um those sample
sites are that's just their name so we
know exactly where they are and and what
they're sort of leading from or to
um so next time I'm I'm happy to share
that with you if you look yep
thank you
any further questions
would someone like to move that the
report be received
somebody else's turned Steward
thanks councilor mcfarl Mr secondary
cancel Phillips
all those in favor please say all right
all right
against
carried
page 58.
click report
56.
page 56 the stormwater discharge consent
for numbers two
206303 206 304 and 206 305 E coli
exceedance investigations three monthly
update
um Aaron again through Mr chair
um this is a requirement on the
stormwater discharge consents that if we
go over a thousand a result over a
thousand then we need to carry out an
investigation and provide three monthly
updates until those investigations are
closed
um
happy to take any questions
counselor mcphail through the G um just
the Poco real situation there
um
how do you get any information from
there with septic tanks and things like
that because I know I've had a property
out there and it has been a bit of an
issue low water tank or the high water
table I should say the
how is that gonna how are you going to
improve that that's or how do we improve
it
um through you Mr chair
um so pokerail was is very
um challenging and trying to find these
um today we have found two failed septic
tanks
um and let us through a smoke machine
that we purchased last year for smoking
the lines
um but yeah it is it is quite a
challenge to fix that out of pokerap
so as in the future how do we move
through on that there's obviously those
septic tanks are going to be getting
older and there was talk of going the
full surge there one stage but I don't
know what but in the meantime you just
got to work with what you've got I
suppose
thank you appreciate that
yeah through you Mr chair um there is
uh the possibility of of doing treatment
and bringing it back to gore but there
is a large capital outlay in doing that
so
yeah
okay
um any more questions
would someone like to move to the report
we received
thanks I mean bill
uh secondary for that thanks
counselor mcphail
all those in favor please say all right
against it's scary
um
material lead protection report
um Aaron again
thank you Mr chair
um
like the report as read and happy to
take any questions
Council streamer
uh through you Mr chair
um have the homeowners that have been
notified have they fixed their leaks and
the other question I have is
um have we considered looking at putting
water meters in not just much air but
we're in Gore as well
um through you Mr chair
upon receiving the information from the
contractor I wrote letters to all the
property owners that had the leaks to
date four people have found the leaks
and repeat them and been verified by us
that that had stopped uh six property
owners have asked for help and
assistance in trying to locate the leaks
um
water meters
to my knowledge haven't been
investigated due to the high Capital
outlay that will be required to install
them
Jack
Jason
um just on the water meters too it's
possibly something that through three
Waters reform I might imagine there
would be something on the radar for that
as well so
yeah
just another comment from another water
scheme was that some of the problem
households they installed meters to them
and then give them a number of work to
you
could be an option in the future
no more questions
counselor Phillips
thank you Mr chair I I just like to
congratulate the staff on finding these
leaks significant significant piece of
work that's probably going to save us a
lot of money in the in the long term and
perhaps then it may be up to the
government script to think about
putting a bylaw in place that residency
don't abide by the the league systems
that we give them a bit of
few nails to hammer in to understand
so then they've got something to go by
and
if if the if the resident wanted to buy
by the leaders and just continues on
with the leak in inside the property and
I think um
we might need seriously have to think
about that uh if the reforms don't come
within a very short space of time
yes thanks
okay because I just um thinking about
the condition of Matera which is a lot
better than the condition of some of the
parts of Gore and I'm just thinking
about
the continuation of the leaked service
within the go area and as soon as
possible I think
catch the Strand
all right through you Mr chair
um the leak that was losing 80 liters a
minute and you weren't particularly on
the surface do we know where that's been
going like do we have a big underground
Kevin now
uh through you Mr chair
um so when they dug it up they didn't
find a big cavity it was just going to
ground in the past of I've seen some
pretty significant leaks that just go to
ground and you never see them so yeah
yeah it's a good find one of those very
good find yeah
um any any further questions
me about
thank you Mr chair is is there any
current incentives Aaron for people you
know when we tell them that they have a
leak do they have a time period they
have to fix it in or any incentive
whatsoever is it really up to the
discretion of the homeowner to fix it
another clients they have
through you Mr chair um so the leader
didn't give a time frame it just asked
them to reach out to me with
um once they had received the leader and
if they wanted any
um help the council was there to assist
and if the leak had been fixed if they
could notify so we can verify it but at
this stage I haven't put a firm deadline
on when it has to be done but as time
rolls on I'm keeping a spreadsheet of it
and we'll be following up and putting
more emphasis on it
personal approach
oops
counselor McKenzie just what pairs do
Council have if people do nothing
can you turn it off
just a point yeah
[Music]
I'll grab that when I feel like pass
through the chair
um so under our water supply bylaw there
is Provisions if
if the council believes is
excessive water wastage at property we
can install a flow meter and measure
that and and charge them based on our
standard fees and charges
um yeah and I guess there is a another
another provision to restrict the water
flow at the site
um if again if we if we think that what
the excessive usage is occurring
um to be honest I don't think in my time
at the council we've ever got to that
stage obviously
um if there's a water leak on a property
it's potentially damaging that property
so there's a bit of that that incentive
for the property owners to get it fixed
as well
thank you Matt
um
I guess that begs the question are any
of these leaks in particular considered
excessive or either within kind of a
regular leak amount
um
um some of the private property ones
um a couple of them were significant and
the rest of them are just general leaks
following up from me speaking about
leaks being under people's houses
causing damage I had a phone call from a
plumber last week that said he got
called to go and fix this toilet when he
went underneath the house there's a big
pool of water from the Waterloo that no
one knew about and he had just received
the letter to say that he had a and he
thought it was his toilet
so
any further questions
counselor mcfarl with the geody um so
let me get this right there's no bylaw
because I know if you have a shrub above
the fence line we get a letter and you
have to get it cut down and we you get
charged if you don't get it done there
must be something there's a knot
the only thing that's what Matt spelled
out is putting a meter in everything
course of action that's fine because
it's the cost it's true directly isn't
it
straight into the time yeah so okay
thank you
through the chair just to clarify there
is a water supply by law
um in place that that covers that and
and spells it out yeah
thank you
give me a bell
is there any ballpark for timelines as
to when you think will be too long or
are you just seeing how how many get
fixed over the next you're just letting
the leader set and seeing how it goes
for now and then or have you got kind of
ideas of when you might do a follow-up
and a a further further letter
through you Mr chair
um my plan was by the end of the month
I'd be doing a follow-up letter to the
residents
um
bearing that in mind I had a phone call
last night from a gentleman that just
received his he lives in Australia so
um he has only just received it
yesterday so he was calling a plumber
this morning to get it resolved but
um I think giving them a month
to make contact or to have it fixed was
a great time line so
counselor
um Neville Phillips thanks Mr chair
possibly that uh it could be one to pass
on to the policy and regularly group for
the decision to make a decision about
whether there's a time frame limited to
put on the on the bylaw so that you guys
have got a bit of so when you put four
weeks on the leader four weeks is four
weeks and you know then you don't have
to have
a guess or putting the pressure on the
manager so if it wasn't written in the
Bible for instance that might be a
better policy
no good idea
we need to talk to you Keith
um any other further questions
sorry I just double checking with Matt
would that would that be helpful to go
down that road
Aaron as well through the chair
um yeah I just I guess we've obviously
got the three Wars reform hovering over
us and um he's updating bylaws can often
be um you know not a quick process so I
wonder if if we wait until perhaps after
the uh elections and and see where the
three Wars reform sits after that
um and and perhaps then look at it um at
that stage
yeah thanks for that Matt and good call
I I guess it won't go on this upcoming
meeting anyways by the time we cycle
back around to the next one it will be
close to election time regardless so
um that committee can assist them thanks
man
councilor Phillips yeah I think it just
needs to be flagged with them just make
a side note that um if nothing's going
to happen within two to three years
we've all we need to have something in
there
Jason can take note of that and we can
follow that up yeah
any further discussion
some would like to move that the report
be received
give me a bell
secondary Stewart
all those in favor please say hi
engaged
carried
so just note that we will follow up put
an extension on
they have a time limit on people fixing
their legs
some sort of method in the future
project register for
met
um he liked fill us in on this one
through the chair um yeah obviously this
is just a summary of the various
significant projects that we have
underway currently
um there's more detailed project updates
provided further along in the agenda
um so perhaps
um we move on to those unless anyone's
got any specific questions about the the
register itself
it's a good quick look yeah
uh we'll move on if no questions on that
one we'll move on to the Elizabeth
Street order of service upgrade
we'll need to receive that report so
first would someone like to move that
councilor Stringer and a secondary
account for Ben Bell
all those in favor please say hi
me or being Bell sorry
all those against
pastors
we'll move on to the first one is
Elizabeth Street
water service upgrade thanks Matt
through the chair
uh yes so I guess this probably this
project
has I suppose been a little bit of a
thorn on our side for the last few
months we felt like we've been very
close to finishing the main reticulation
in the street for a number of months now
and and still haven't quite got there
um although I guess it's pleasing to
report that Fulton Hogan were very close
to to
um does establishing from sight
um or be it they are planning to return
in Spring
um to finish off some road construction
work berm reinstatements and a small
amount of drainage work that yeah I
guess we've agreed it's best to hold off
until we've got some better weather
rather than I'll try and do it now and
and
the risk would be that it would take
longer and we get a poorer quality
finish I'm trying to do it in during
winter
um
yeah and but I guess
um just to adding to that we've made it
quite clear to Fulton Hogan that the the
strait needs to be reinstated to an
acceptable level before they just
establish to minimize any disruption
to Residents
um in the interim
um and I guess the other thing I'll
commonly intern is is the private
property separation work
um
progress with that and using local
plumbers is I guess been
um reasonably slow over the last few
months
um I guess we're hoping that
um
the the Plumber's workload will start to
ease up and and they'll have some more
resources available to get that work
done
um and at least we're just starting to
have conversations with with the
plumbers that we are using around the
fact that if they can't commit to
um some more steady progress we're going
to have to start looking at using some
plumbers based on invercargill or
something like that to make sure that we
get through that work
happy to take any questions
Council Phillips
thank you Mr chair yeah thanks Matt for
that all right
um excuse my back
yeah Mike my concern was that um
this was the the first time the council
has undertaken the private separation
and my concern was that December
deadline there's a few months out and
there's a lot of costs between now and
December
um coming back onto the right bar and
I'm pleased to hear that you have put
the emphasis back onto the
plumbers who are
designed onto this project to get their
a into G and get it done because
um I presume that their procurement is
in their own risk is it not ears is that
correct the or the pipe work
or have we purchased the public
through the chair that's correct the the
plumber is purchasing all the materials
um themselves
so they they're hearing lies my concern
that by December
their price is probably going to Triple
or double
um and
they're not going to worry too much
about coming there straight away as a
priority job because
they know that this job is going to last
till December they've end
if I was a plumber I'd be getting the
um
other wee jobs done first because it's a
known thing that I've got income coming
in later on after I've finished these
jobs so yeah I'm glad you're putting the
pressure on them
councilor Stringer
yeah three Mr chair
um I see the driveway repairs have been
removed from the project but the cost is
being shared
four
through the chair yeah so sorry just
what I mean by that is uh
the driveway repairs have been removed
from the Fulton Hogan contract
um but this project will still fund a
portion of those driveway rare
statements and the roading department
will fund the other portion where we're
replacing sections that haven't actually
been affected by this work yeah
Council Australia
it's just another question it's not so
much about the report there but
the Basin that you've got at the End of
the Street obviously for taking flood
events
what is the risk for people ending up on
that when it's seventh form or full
through the chair yeah this is something
that we've discussed
and length and
um there's not a lot of Industry
guidance or I guess there's a lot of
confusion in the industry around us
um
stormwater basins a reasonably common in
other parts of town and other parts of
the country
and I'm not aware of
many if any that are fenced
I know
the Auckland design standards so that
fencing's not normally required
and yeah I'm gonna
I guess it
um
you know if you look at that site and in
most sites
um
the the risk of the Road Traffic that's
on the other side of the footpath is
significantly higher than the Basin
that's you know full
on a relatively infrequent
um
cycle
um yeah so so at this stage we've deemed
the risk not requiring
um
fencing but yeah we can review that at
any stage
just Jason will comment on us
you just uh through the chair further to
Matt's comments so this is
um certainly an item that's on our sort
of health and safety risk
um agenda
we've been looking at that Basin and
also the one at Metro Ridge and just at
this stage that's our approach but
certainly
um during we'll be monitoring that as
closely during any significant rain
events just to see how they are
functioning see what sort of water is
pulling and then that will give us a
better indication of
um what that risk or perceived risk is
and we can then address it but we
haven't ruled out fencing but at this
stage we're sort of looking at
um
all the information this purpose because
yeah we sort of we want to make sure
that there is some green space there
that can be utilized as well as part of
these and so we want to make it usable
and add to the ascetics too of of the
streetscapes if we can and sort of but
if we steam it the risk to get higher
then we will look at fencing as an
option
any further questions
Mia being bail
well I I guess that once again begs the
question of if we end up in the the
situation that we've been in at the
start of the year
um with work safe becoming involved what
is our liability there if we do have a
terrible terrible event happen again
um
will it be the same scenario or yeah I
guess what what risks do we have there
he would like to comment on that
episode through you Mr chair I guess the
what we should do is take some advice
from the industry because what worksafe
normally do is comment on on any
industry standard that they may be out
there in terms of recommendations for
say for example fencing a water body the
issue you have here of course is that
predominantly it'll be dry but on a
flood event it will be have water which
could prove to be a hazard so what I
would recommend we do is actually find
out
talk to work safe and in any
industry standard we know out there so
that we can be assured that we are
taking all due
um
care to eliminate a risk but to talk to
go to the point of Jason that we don't
want to detract from the Aesthetics of
the area and it's actually a green space
which is quite attractive and probably
95 of the time is probably going to be
just a um
a wee bowl with some green grass for
people to generally enjoy in that
neighborhood so if that's of the wish of
the committee we can take some advice
and report back about what that advice
might be
thank you
can you take note of that Jason
any further questions
if not I'll put the um let the report be
received once I would like to move that
Stuart and signature counselor strainer
all those in favor please say aye
engaged it's carried
we'll move over to the next report is
the escort Water Treatment Plant upgrade
project update
um for Matt again
foreign
with one I guess outstanding issue being
a
one piece of equipment at the site
creating a
a noise issue for the immediate
neighbors
um and so we met with the contractor
last week in the outlands
their plans to resolve the issue both to
us and and the affected residents
and they're just waiting on some final
pieces of information
before they come up to
the work that they'll be doing in a time
frame so we'd like to have that
commitment I'd expect in the next week
or two
I suspect the the all the work will take
um three or four months to complete
um
but but yeah I think
we're happy and the affected resident
seems to be happy with with the progress
and what's being proposed at this point
able to take any questions thank you
against the Phillips
thank you Mr chair uh just a question
about then is this a design fault uh
just an unseen fault
is it Air cost or is it the completion
of the insulation insulator
it's through the chair I guess the first
thing to note is uh the contract that
the council awarded was a design build
contract to the the contractor so while
it is a designer shoots um the
contractor's problem to resolve it
and it is a cost to the contractor
rather than to the council
thank you
any further questions
we will wait what happens I suppose yeah
um would someone like to move that this
report will be received
thank you Neville
Council of Neville Phillips and a
secondary
Council Stringer all those in favor
please say aye
against carried
uh the Wickham Street Wastewater remains
replacement update
it's right on their eyes at the moment
yeah
thanks Matt
through the chair is probably the
biggest
um of first I know that the the
constructional site's going reasonably
well
um
it's obviously the reason we complicated
project in terms of particularly the
location that they're working with in
the significance of the part that
they're working on but we're pretty
happy with the performance of the
contractor today
um
since right in this report we have
managed to obtain the necessary permit
from kiwi Rail and allowing us to
complete the works through the rail
corridor
so that's
progressing as we speak
um and there's a what they call a block
of line which means a period where
they're going to shut the railway tracks
down so that we can do the work actually
underneath the railway tracks so that's
occurring this weekend so the contract
is busy getting ready for that there's a
certain amount of pipe that he needs to
install before he can do the section
under the railway tracks
um and I guess that
um
you you've possibly noticed that they've
done halfway across the the state
highway and then stopped and that that's
all around this key rail permit issue
they had about a week where we didn't
have the permit and the only work that
we could progress was across the state
highway so rather than sit around and do
nothing for a week that did that and
then it returned back to do the section
through the QR land
so I'd expect
um to be probably about about two weeks
for them to finish off the section
through the key around before they then
get back out onto the state highway and
finish off going across the state
highway and through the playground and
to complete the project
happy to take any questions
any questions counselor stronger
thank you Mr chair
um thanks for that you've answered my
first question which was going to be
regarding the permit
um
the other one Nemo's
[Music]
um
so going under or through the rail
Corridor are they actually needing to
remove track to do it or are they
thrusting or they bursting and what is
our Russell Watts what is the risk if
they don't get it done in their
allocated time do we have to then
reapply for another permit is any loss
upon the contract or is that fall back
on us
through the chair
um
yes so um
I guess the first thing is they're three
days allowed for the block of line and
um
were reasonably comfortable with that
time frame we're working pretty closely
with kiwi Rail and kiro's contractor so
um
they will be lifting up the track the
key rail contractor will be lifting up
the tracks
um and and then putting them back and
and we'll do the work obviously in
between that
um
yeah and and so yeah I guess the biggest
risk is probably around the weather and
we can't replace the pipe
um during rain event because the float
flows are too big uh fortunately the
weather forecast is looking reasonably
fine for the upcoming weekend uh
touchwood
um and yeah there is another block of
line I think it's is it late June 24th
yeah 24th of June that if we if we did
um miss this one we could we could work
towards that one but obviously at the
end of the the block line that's coming
up we have to have the railway tracks
back in place and operational yeah
any further questions
and councilor Phillips
the university and that's not so much a
question but it just uh
the delay actually helped I think for
the time delay it was uh well timed
considering what's this to happen the
last 10 days and I think you can imagine
what the
consequences might have been if that
road had been shut off in the last 10
days and it's been really good I think
good timing
yes
I thought it would be good be good to
see that projects finish turn to the
railway it'd be it looks major the other
question I had was what's the difference
in size between the new pipe and the old
pipe
through the chair um so it's essentially
the pipe's going to have the same
capacity
um but the the existing pipe is an
egg-shaped uh pipe that's sort of
approximately one meter high and about
500 millimeters wide and so we're
changing that out with a standard 900
diameter circular pipe
um
so yeah essentially the same capacity
but but different show
thank you
any further questions
I would like to put this report that the
report would be received would someone
like to move there
councilor Stewart
Victor now
secondary Council Mr Stringer
all those in favor please say hi
against it's carried
sorry Mr chair I just need to be excused
thank you very much
station ponds project update from Matt
again thank you
thank you Mr chairman uh look I'll just
comment that this project is going very
well and we're very happy with the
performance of the contractor on it
um and you're happy to take any
questions
any questions for this one
councilor Phillips no it's not not so
much equation just once again uh
congratulations finally getting some
some results after
this length period of time that we've
been in and out of oxidation ponds and
yeah thanks thanks to the staff
I would agree I'd agree with that
especially after Alaska
now did you have any questions
it's not a question just to state but
I'm I think it must be going quite well
because I've had no one call me about it
so
that's all
thank you
no no further questions I'd like to put
the report be received although someone
like to move that report
councilman McKenzie moved that one and
Council Phillip seconded it
thank you all those in favor please say
aye
against carried
let's watch over to the gore and
material Wastewater consent renewal
project update thank you Matt
hey Mr chairman
um yeah so again this this Project's
going to reuse me well
um
although
we are in terms of time frame so we
originally agreed to have the resource
consent application through to
environment South and in about April
next year and just I guess that time
frame is starting to get a little bit
tighter
uh the technical working group
um seems to be working pretty well and
um particularly we get in in a meeting
here that we we seem to be able to reach
you can consensus and agreement on
things so that's that's really pleasing
um one thing I will flag chairs that
we're hoping
um we're just we're just penciling in
um a governance group Hui
um
so we're aiming for Friday the 21st of
July at 1pm and the idea behind that is
that'll be a joint
Hui between uh the elected council
members and the hokano irunanga
leadership team
and at that meeting we'll be going over
the
investigation work that's been completed
um with um the aim of identifying a
short list of options for more detailed
investigation
um which will then obviously would
expect a preferred option to fall out
um and as part of that Howie will also
be asking for some feedback on
criteria as to what those shortlisted
options
um how they'll be ranked or how how
they'll be selected
but you'll be hoping for a good
attendance there
um if possible
thank you is there any questions
counselor mcphail thanks
um yeah thanks for that through the
treatment
um
um do we are we going to get some info
on are we going to get some info on that
before we go to that so that we're sort
of heads up
those that you're talking about the
cultural concerns of what the discharges
is it what you're talking about
we'll get something before we go
yeah we could have a think about that
um so the the Hui will will be a
workshop so we won't
um I guess
um we wouldn't be looking for you to
make any decisions
um and
yeah be with uh I'm a whether we want to
present that information and then
provide you with the reports just or
potentially can provide the reports
prior to the workshop but it may be a
bit confusing so
um yeah we can have a think about that
um sounding like your preference would
be to get some material beforehand just
so we have a bit of a heads up about
what possibly could be put in front of
us
sure yeah we're not sitting there um
looking blank
no thank you
no it's good to hear there is some
agreement and yeah I'm moving forward
any further questions
councilor Phillips uh is it possible to
get that on the calendar Mr chair
it's uh just been added
thank you
oh not quite yet what will be
any other questions
Council Australia
with some of you removing that report
thank you Council Springer
and uh is there a secondary
Council McKenzie thank you
change your practice
all those in favor please say hi
all right against
and it's carried
we'll move over to the Matera river
crossing the project update on that
quite
um quite a major project
thank you Mr chairman
uh yeah so obviously um the council
recently made a decision to focus on
drilling a pipe underneath the river as
opposed to the proposed shared use
Bridge
and following on from that we've now
engaged Becca to do a Geotech
investigation we've had
input from a directional driller around
the recommended investigation work to be
completed
um and we will shortly be issuing out a
expression of interest for the for the
drilling component of the work
and that that's around getting an
understanding as to the capacity and
capability of the
Contracting Market to complete that work
and then once with an understanding of
that that'll I guess guide our
procurement plan
um
it does obviously a reasonably
specialist work and there'll be a
limited number of contractors that are
capable of doing it
um I guess in that expression of
Interest we have while it you know the
preference as as for directional
drilling we have left it a little bit
open so that if there is a contractor
out there that thinks
um they can do it cost effectively and
efficiently by another method
um I.E trenching
um lift it open at this stage
um
but yeah our thoughts are the most
likely outcome is that it'll be drilled
um councilor McKenzie question
it's just a comment really he's still
getting a bit of communication from Jack
Mack
he's very he's very keen on doing a
ditch across the river he just likes to
know that he's being heard that's all
through the chair I I don't think we've
heard anything since the community
engagement
um closed
um he's been in for a chat with me I can
tell you is it yeah I mean I I guess I
know there's a lot of discussion out in
the community about trenching through
the river yeah my nervousness is really
around
um I can't find any
examples of a similar scale of work
being completed
um and and so if people are aware of
um you know projects where a pipeline's
been trenched through a river
um in New Zealand
of that scale
um I'd be quite Keen to hear about it
it's it's not totally off the box it's
probably what people would like to hear
well that's yeah that's correct yeah
thank you I presume I presume trenching
would trigger a consent though wouldn't
it
yeah that that is another significant
challenge
um that would need to be overcome if
you're going to go down that path
councilor Stringer
uh through you Mr chair
um the expressions of Interest that'll
go up on the government gets system cool
that's cool thank you
just a question how many people do you
suppose would take up trenching add
drilling do you uncontracted wise
through the chair that I mean there's
certainly one that we know that's that's
capable of doing it
um potentially another one or two
um but you know I'd be surprised if we
got more than more than three
yeah
thank you
no more questions
someone like a council mcfowl
through the chair just sorry just a view
on that we've gone through the process
with the public
and we've explained that we were looking
at going under the river now we've got
to be very careful that we if we look at
the trenching side of things that we
don't go down this part another that
path without because talking to the
people because this has happened before
and we don't want that to happen again I
don't personally don't want that to
happen again just want to make a point
of that that's all just to think very
carefully
thank you
any comment on that map
yeah I mean
um that would obviously
um all come back through the council if
we're going to go through that path and
I don't uh
yeah
oh yeah
entirely up to the council
um as to whether they want to go down
that path and would obviously need to
talk to hokanoir and things like that
um I think the key thing around the
decision that the council bag was that
they were moving away from the bridge
and focusing on a pipeline across the
bridge a river
[Music]
um
yeah
thank you
no further questions
are you moving that councilman file the
report will be received
thank you so secondary
councilman MacDonald
all those in favor please say aye
against
carried
haven't heard anything from David are
you still there
material Water Treatment Plant upgrade
um
Matt thanks
thank you Mr chairman oh yeah again this
this Project's tracking along fairly
nicely
um contractors seem to be performing
quite well
um there have been sort of a number of
minor variations and and design changes
and things uh required but that's
perhaps not an unexpected given that
it's um you know the upgrade and
refurbishment of an existing treatment
plant some of the things we I guess
we're aware of but couldn't quantify
until some of the demolition Works was
completed or or filters were taken out
of service and things like that
um
yeah and I guess at this stage here
we're on track
um
to have things completed sort of late
this year
um nearing um quite a critical stage
where uh the new electrical equipment
will be installed and the first filter
will be brought into service so to
expect that to happen over the next
month and from there that'll then allow
them to take the second filter out of
service and start the refreshment work
on that
happy to take any questions
any questions
looks like a good report and a good
contractor yeah
someone like to move that this report we
received
councilor Australia
it's a secretary Council Phillips they
keep all those in favor please say aye
against carried
the last next one is the hillbury Avenue
Water tear demolition project
through the chair
um yeah again so this Project's changed
somewhat following the decision to hold
off on the demolition of the tower
itself and consider that as part of the
uh 2024 long term plan
but we are still progressing with the
correct construction of new pump station
so preparation work for that's been
completed on site
and we're just working through the
building consent process and working
through some requests from information
that's come out of that but would expect
to
have that consent sooner rather later
allowing the construction of the actual
Pump Station to get underway
any any questions
looks reasonably straightforward most
projects are these days are they
would someone like to move that that
report be received
thanks
councilman mcnell and any secondary
councilor Phillips all those in favor
please say aye
against
carried
that brings us to the end of our open
meeting
um
we'll have a short break but